Is Gutter Snipe a good card in
commander? It's a popular enough instant
and sorcery payoff, so surely the answer
is yes. Well, it might be, but it also
might be dead weight that's holding you
back. And it all depends on the rest of
what's in your deck and your goals
within the game. Obviously, you want a
lot of instance and sorceries, but you
also want them low cost enough that
you're casting multiple per turn cycle.
On hello, the painter decks tend to run
a lot of instance and sorceries, but
most of them are high cost, meaning that
gutters snipe is often better as an
overcosted sacrifice choice than it is
as a damage dealer. The other
requirement for making gutters snipe
good is that your deck actually cares
about incremental damage. If you're a
spell slinger deck full of similar
pingers and cards that create evasive
flyers, incremental damage is going to
be a big part of your game plan. So,
gutters snipe will feel meaningful.
However, if your deck is closer to a
combo or control deck with fewer of
these effects, the chunks of two damage
that our goblin friend dishes out might
not actually be helping you achieve your
deck's goals.